everyone this is Steve on trip with
Collider and I am here with everyone
behind us thank you so much for coming
in the studio here at South by Southwest
before we get started I want to give a
huge thank you to supper sweet hint
water Red Nose Day all the people
responsible for helping us be here
covering festivals is what we call
expensive and sponsors are important and
I just want to say and sincere thank you
let me start by saying how much this
this you guys all did such a great job
and the reaction last night in the
theater was so huge what was it like
being in that theater watching it
because no one in that theater had seen
it prior to last night it was such a
great audience and I loved hearing
everybody's reactions because there were
some parts in the movie where we didn't
so it was a good way to kind of you know
it was yeah it was really electrifying
to experience it with an audience that
was so ready for it and so receptive and
responsive yeah you know there were
definitely things being said and we were
overhearing that was ludicrous but it
was really great to see how this film
plays in in a group and to feel the
suspense and the titillation as well
that was that it was occurring in the
room also to just feel the ABS and flows
of the movie through the lens of the
audience like knowing when the room is
really tense and then one of those gags
that the jump out things happen and
everyone's like it's really good to feel
that and feel that you know the
intention is having the impact that you
intended and it was just like you said
electrifying you felt the kinetic energy
and they were just attached you know
there are scenes with Shehadeh that
people that
yeah that's right get him so when people
are that responsive and there are
talking to the screen there they become
another character for you know our film
you know and and it's really just
refreshing to finally meet that
character yeah it was really nice hard
to see people react
I was looking like all around this
theater it's like oh how is he gonna
react how she gonna react because I had
still got scared for some of it like
that's and I want to see if anybody else
gets scared because there are a lot of
things that I was scared I was scared
out that no one else was I understand
I'm I don't think you'd be able to see
this movie if you were not in it
[Applause]
I'm curious one of these things about
this movie is you can't really talk too
much about it without ruining some of
the twists and turns so how have you
been describing it to like friends and
family and how much are you willing to
say about the actual plot so I'm ready I
already saw the movie before last night
so I was you know I was telling my
friends and family that I had already
seen the movie but I couldn't reveal too
much so you know as you said I called it
like electrifying exciting a crazy
adventure you know it's you have to get
some good vocabulary words to draw
people into the theaters so that they
can you know get to see more than just
the trailer right but I think it's safe
to say that the film is about a family
of the Wilson family who go on a summer
vacation to their summer home in Santa
Cruz and Adelaide Wilson who I play is
that is riddled with trauma from her
childhood that she can't really explain
and she has a foreboding sense that
something bad is gonna happen and it
she's proven right when these four
shadowy figures show up at the top of
their driveway and then their worst
nightmare ensues and that's all okay
families story about how to move forward
a lot of people are essentially figuring
out what's the best way they could move
their lives forward in this film and you
know that's how I would put it it's just
a families attempt to move forward the
thing that I think this movie does
brilliantly is it can play on multiple
levels it's an action movie it's a quasi
zombie type movie it also has a lot of
subtext that for the people that want to
dig in there's a lot of underlying
messages here it's very rare for
Hollywood to make movies like this that
are artistic and just it this kind of
multi-layered kind of a thing talk a
little bit about the fact that well
maybe if you would touch on that a
little bit about Jordan's writing it
does so much with this material and it
plays on so many different levels well
for one just the fact that the Wilsons
are just a normal happy healthy black
family is so so different unfortunately
you know you don't really get to see a
lot of that in horror movies because you
know representation is just so important
for young black girls or just anybody
that looks like us because I remember
when I was younger I wasn't very content
with just being black so I think that it
was really important for Jordan to let
the viewers see this family that look
exactly like them yeah and yeah Jordan
writes layered story and he also pays
homage to cinema and to the horror genre
he brings all that into his story into
his storytelling so he you know he did
that with this film and what it does for
us as actors it gives us a lot to
masticate on you know to really dig deep
and and just challenge ourselves to go
deeper and darker especially in this
kind of yeah and yeah it's a real
opportunity to play and he's always
refining as you shoot you know he's
always reconsidering and rican
sexualizing we but at the heart of it he
has something there he has a kernel of
truth that he's trying to investigate
and and he stays true to that kernel of
truth I think it's important to also
discuss of how he is redefining the
iconography that we see every day so we
don't usually think of our black family
as the all-american family and the
all-american normal and we're doing that
with this phone we're saying this is
what normal could look like so yes this
does look like and essentially this is
what your culture is so it actually
doesn't separate anyone from the culture
it actually says this is your culture
and it asks everyone to see themselves
in the Wilson's
so whatever change they go through it
puts you in that shoe it puts you in
those shoes to ask how are you like this
what are your things that you're hiding
what are your what are your demons
what are your scissors you know so it
really it's very inclusive in a great
way they all said they were like
electrified to see this but I was fired
up like doing
it was unexpected like I'd always seen
myself at this really good comedian but
for joining to do this was like really
important because a lot of horror movies
I see haven't been like a black family
probably cuz I don't see horror movies
it was really cool it just seems black
movie but then when Jordan do like a
horror foo of blackboard that was also
like really cool because I haven't seen
a black horror film this film has some
very intense scenes that looked like
they were also very challenging to shoot
with the level of detail and in shots
can you guys share a little bit of what
it was like on set filming some of those
I don't want to do any spoilers but some
pretty intense stuff prosthetics
prosthetics were really hard like the
makeup crew and Sabrina they're all like
really good at it because the makeup
looks so real when I put it on and they
kept doing that over and over again and
I was like observing how they are doing
it and it looks so real for the intense
scenes I think that we really all of us
I think everybody had to get into this
different mood and this different kind
of you know mode as soon as we you know
walked on set you know the feeling was
really different than us being the
Wilsons you know going to Santa Cruz and
you know that really helped pull the
scene all together it made it look more
realistic and you know it it gives a
different feeling for the audience to
portray there was a lot of support on
the center yeah there was a lot of
support in everything so even anything
that seemed complicated they tried to
make it as simple for us to execute as
possible
you know the swimming the night shoots
you know changing you know there were my
experience of playing both Abraham and
Gabe was that I didn't have to play them
both a lot of times on the same day and
that helped because playing Abraham
required a certain amount of just work
and investment and a different mindset
than Gabe Gabe was a whole different
experience so not having to do those
things a lot on one day really helped
and to have Jordan really support us on
the days when we were one family looking
at the other family was really helpful
so it was just a set of incredible
support every single day and also the
cast that would check in with each other
have lunch with each other always like
like oh man and seeing this little guy
in a cool different way how do I bring
that into the story where I am that
attached and and want to protect him and
want to change his future you know like
being able to spend time and have lunch
with you really changed everything as
well I mean but I think it was a
challenge to act against yourself and
never meet your scene partner that was
kind of like a it was twisted but yes we
did have incredible support and Jordan
was actually awesome for me what he
would often do when he would play cuz
he's such a good mimic impressionist and
so he would often play he would on the
mic play the other character and that
was really really helpful because you
know he's so good at it you think it
would be funny but he was actually
intriguing because he would kind of own
it you know he was not making fun of you
he was actually trying to give you as
much as he could so that he could do
your best performance and I think that
like the coolest thing to have a
director who could do that who could
take on that kind of responsibility so
that you actually working with a with a
spirited version of your other side it
also add to the shock value on that day
too right yeah
I obviously don't want to do spoilers
but there's a lot of stuff in this movie
and I'm curious how much after reading
the script how much did you you know how
much did you get into if you will with
Jordan about the specifics of the iconic
what we're seeing and the meaning behind
certain things how much did you sort of
put it all together in the script
how much was Jordan telling you on set
to sort of let you know do you know what
I mean yeah like reading the script was
like it was almost like reading a really
good book because I would I would read
it like on the train on my way to school
and I read it on the way home and it was
just amazing and I could tell that it
was it was you know amazingly written
because I would you know memorize those
pages in like seconds and I would be
like oh my god this is like incredible
and then on set he would tell us more
about the meanings and the you know
symbolism of you know the scissors and
the rabbits and stuff like that and it
really helped pull the authenticity
together we're always in conversation
and great thing about Jordan is that he
respects everyone's individual process
and my individual process requires a lot
of conversation I like to have more
information than less you know so he
always you know engaged me and I always
had a lot of questions about the world
about the physics of the world and you
know the the rules I wanted to know the
rules at all times and then he also
allowed you to just play to have your
own process and you can share that with
him and he'll make it a comfortable
space I in regards to how much I knew of
the themes and things like that I knew
it was a
peel script so there's a lot of subtext
so I I personally hired like a dramaturg
to go through my script with me and I'll
ask him to do research on like the color
red or you know what scissors mean in
different literature through time and
sit in cinema and you know different
things like that that helped me really
understand the world that we're playing
in and what different things can mean
than just make bolder choices and lean
into function yeah Jordan is very
generous with information he's very
communicative and he will let you know
what themes he's pulling for what
references he's pulling from and
everything like that one of the things
he did was recommend 10 films for me to
watch that that he felt was were
references you know for his he's
approached to this film and his style in
general so I had to do that homework
which was not easy but I did it and some
of the films came with enter at your own
risk
she's rich he loves horror films she was
so easy about it but so so there was
that but then also yes those lengthy
conversations because he really he's at
he's kind of inviting us to create with
him and I invited Jordan into my
personal creative process more
intimately than I have ever done with
any other director because he's so
respectful of our process so I knew he
wasn't interested in tampering with it
and I knew that the more he understood
about what was what was interesting to
me what I was drawn to the more he could
support it and you know
and the more I could support his vision
it's very interesting because there are
certain filmmakers like a David Lynch
who will try to be very mysterious about
what he's displaying on screen and leave
it up to the viewers imagination if you
will it's interesting to hear Jordans
process being more collaborative and
informative show us a lot of footage
like right after I personally love being
involved as much as I can because I like
to know again function so I can know
what my characters job is and if I know
what my job is I can be as aggressive at
doing that as possible without caring
about how I look or sound or feel you
know that gets me from being nervous to
be honest right and that's the thing
about Jordan is that he would cater he
would tailor make his directing style to
each of us so for example Winston loves
playback and he would always be in the
video village looking at what we just
did and I I'm averse to it so he would
protect me from the playback and and and
that kind of thing I think makes him an
exceptional director because he meets us
where we are and then you know and he
gave us a lot of freedom and how we
wanted our characters to look both of
them you know he would ask us about
things you know what they would do
personally and it really helped us and
it helped you know make the the stunt
doubles look more realistic or you know
we could wax poetic about Jordan peel
all day because it was that kind of
experience where every day you'd come
back rienne like just re-energized every
week and you were like running for your
life just it's so hard to put into words
how much agency from day one you know
he'd line are our doubles up and say you
know these guys know their characters
way more than
ever know so please take any direction
from them about what to do with your
doppelgangers or physicality because
they're creating something and I work
with them but I want them to just let
you know what their process is like so
we we felt onus you know we felt
ownership as well and and and that's
really important as an artist I'm gonna
ask this is my last thing because you
guys have to go I think a lot of people
are curious whether or not this film
because everyone's interested in shared
universes and whatnot
does the film take place in the same
universe as get out okay
there was a theory that this was like a
get out - but I'm not sure that because
it was like totally different from get
out in a way many ways like she said
because Jordans mine had to work like so
differently from get out like get out
was this revolution like this weird
thing because I and watching this it was
like they're like it's just like like
their faces are so similar the way
things just so similar but the things
that are happening are just so different
so for me that would be like a no so the
cinematography was alike but you know
what I mean though it goes like shared
universes if you will like all let's use
the term Star Wars all the Star Wars
movies take place in the same universe
yes so I think the universe that Jordan
is working with is earth-like he's
actually working with the world as we
know it right I think with this film
there is a little more fantasy in
creating these monsters called a
tethered you know and in a way that in
get out the monsters
so that is I think more realistic this
one takes a few more liberties in the
horror film genre but he is
allegorically I think metaphorically
he's asking us to look at our world as
it is you know so the universe is his
mind but his mind has very many
different worlds I suppose I would say
it's just dimensions
I'd say its dimensions within one
universe created by Jordan because I
think that because I think that like
both of the stories are totally
different you know and Jordans made it
very clear that like the story isn't
about race but it is important to have a
black family you know starring and I
think that was really important and you
know unfortunately it is very
controversial but that's how it is right
now I just want to I have to stop and
just say that you guys all did such
great work in the movie
I say nothing but congratulations and
thank you so much for stopping in and
seriously have a fantastic
south-by-southwest
thank you and we are out
you